the employees at Heckert have
experienced a lot in the past 25 years
under communism 4300 people worked in
what was then a state-owned
machine-tools factory but german
reunification in 1990 bought rapid
change a new beginning privatisation
bankruptcy and another new beginning
over the years thousands of employees
lost their jobs staff constantly feared
for their livelihood Heckert is now
owned by a swiss investor and business
is looking up and les Tilda has seen it
all the design engineer has worked it
for 30 years and has been a member of
the company's works counselor for
fifteen of them I think it's always
important that the company is healthy
because that's the only way we can hold
on to our jobs and that's ultimately
what counts Tilda is on first-name terms
with sales manager Michele Fiedler he
sees himself as a mediator between
management and the workforce Heckert has
dropped out of Germany's collective
labor agreements that means that unions
no longer negotiate wages instead
employee representatives negotiate
directly with their bosses today nearly
half of companies in Germany work this
way
it's easier for us to work this way than
to accept contracts agreed somewhere
else that perhaps wouldn't suit us if we
can't communicate directly with each
other and solve the problems then why
should others be able to do it no
collective wage agreement that usually
means less take-home pay and that rule
of thumb also applies at heckard but
they trust their works council chairman
to get the best deal for them about 90%
of employees voted for tilt nur in the
last election here we go states based on
market conditions have been some lean
years when he held off on demands our
main competitors are no longer based in
Italy or Spain today they come mainly
from Asia China Japan Taiwan or Korea
that means we can't worry about German
export surpluses or a lack of purchasing
power when it comes to the level we're
competing at I think we've struck a very
good balance between economic
achievement and letting the employees
benefit there are no temporary workers
or freelance work contracts here just
permanent staff the employees appreciate
this feeling of security it also makes
the company attractive to workers from
the region
most often people ask me about
interesting tasks what the work climate
is here how teams work together in such
questions it's amazing that money isn't
always the first thing on their minds of
course the employees would still welcome
more money early next year Tilda will
begin a new round of wage negotiations
but first he'll take a close look at the
company's finances to see how much more
money he can extract for his colleagues
the majority would spend it and if they
saved it it would only be because
they're uncertain about the future
uncertainty is exactly what and last
owner wants to avoid he believes there's
no benefit to higher wages if they lead
to job cuts later